so as you guys all know i've been
putting a ton of hours into watching
apple's
developer tutorial videos from wwdc
with a focus on trying to figure out the
ins and outs
of apple silicon but just yesterday
i discovered apple's platform's state of
the union video
which is an hour and a half long and let
me tell you guys
i found some stuff in there that is so
impressive that it's gonna knock your
socks off
and remove any doubts you have of apple
silicon
being great for the mac and for some
reason
i haven't seen anybody else on youtube
talking about what's in that video
and by the way i just created a new
apple silicon max
explained playlist that i'll link to at
the end of this video
and they basically show off things like
how the new chips will work
why this is going to revive gaming on
the mac why apple silicon
won't have discrete gpus and much more
so definitely check that out after this
video is over
now before we dig into the one and a
half hour long video from apple
i want to show you guys something very
interesting about apple silicon
that my brother max just discovered if
you're familiar with the camera space
you probably heard about the new canon
eos r5 camera
and the fact that it uses an
unconventional hevc
422 format well he tried editing some
footage from that camera on various
computers
and even his fifteen thousand dollar mac
pro struggled with it
until he brought it onto his ipad pro
where it played back perfectly smooth
the reason for that is because the ipad
pro has
apple silicon and apple silicon has
special hevc hardware transcoders
and all of that is also coming to the
mac
and likely getting improved on top of
that so it's very likely that the very
first
13-inch macbook pro with apple silicon
is gonna edit
this modern footage better than a lot of
high-end computers
and just this morning the nda was lifted
off of the brand new
sony a7s3 camera and that camera
also shoots using the hevc codec because
it's the future
of video recording and apple silicon is
ready for it so without further ado
let's get right into that video using
every silicon inside max is an amazing
direction
for the future it will open the door for
huge improvements to speed
graphics performance power consumption
security
and more i don't know if you caught that
but he said
huge improvements to graphics
performance
so while it seems like ditching
dedicated graphics is a bad thing
apple has some tricks up their sleeve
unifying architectures across our
product lines will allow us to bring
unmodified iphone and ipad apps to the
mac
for the first time we've been working on
it for several years and we are so happy
with the result
yes he just said unmodified iphone and
ipad games
meaning no changes whatsoever from the
app developer
meaning that the very first apple
silicon mac will have access to the
entire
ios app store on day one and those apps
are gonna work
perfectly as you'll see in just a minute
productivity apps like iworks pages
numbers and keynote
run great and this is one of the most
demanding pro apps final cut pro
with real-time rendering of several
movie streams and logic our music
creation powerhouse
easily keeping up with large projects we
already worked with a number of our
partners to bring the apps to apple
silicon as well
here's adobe photoshop already taking
advantage of the new architecture
and running fast on this new mac and
microsoft has brought up their office
apps
such as word and excel of course our
developer tools also work great on apple
silicon and can be used to create native
apps
and as you can see here in activity
monitor when we say bixer and all the
software is running great on apple
silicon
we really mean it every single bit of
code you just saw is 100 native
so basically adobe and microsoft have
been working directly with apple
to get all of their productivity apps
running natively
on apple silicon so if you use photoshop
lightroom premiere pro any microsoft app
or any apple app like final cut logic
pro 10 or
x code they should all work great on
day one max will be more secure they'll
be faster and more responsive
they'll have longer battery life and
they would simply be much better overall
for graphics
making the mac an amazing platform for
games for example
so that confirms it better battery life
and much better overall for graphics
specifically for gaming which we'll get
into in just a minute
and for the first time the mac will have
a dedicated inference accelerator
for machine learning applications with a
neural engine coming over to the mac of
course one of the things i'm
most excited about is that we're
bringing our high performance gpu
architecture to the mac
we've already seen our gpu architecture
do really well
in the iphone and ipad pro and in the
mac this architecture is going to be
great
for pro application and games so we're
getting new machine learning
accelerators
the new neural engine and apparently
even more high performance graphics
for pro apps and games this transition
will give our developers a common
architecture behind
all of our products so whether you're
building software for the apple watch
iphone ipad pro and now the mac there's
a unified scalable architecture behind
all of them which should make it easier
to write and optimize your application
across all of our platforms it really is
a really exciting time
and there you have it from apple
themselves the change the apple silicon
is going to make
writing and optimizing apps much easier
for developers
since you have a common architecture
across
all of apple's platforms so we should
start seeing even more apps and games
for the mac
than ever before and performance will be
off the charts in many areas
in particular the apple silicon unified
memory architecture powerful gpus in our
highly optimized method apis
are going to allow for responsive
complex image editing workflows
such as the one you see here in affinity
photo or cinema 4d
an app optimized for metal for real-time
interactive 3d
editing and modeling you can see how
smoothly it runs on apple silicon
every mac with apple silicon is going to
have that powerful gpu and metal
implementation
making max a fantastic platform for
running games like dirt rally at high
frame rates
i don't know about you but apple seems
to be focusing a lot
on gaming as you can easily see the
neural engine allows for a whole new
experience
and a mac with an apple soc finished the
task much quicker
so for machine learning applications
apple silicon
is gonna be the way to go max will stay
max the way you know and love them
they will run the same powerful pro apps
they will offer the same developer apis
macs have today
they will let users create multiple
volumes on disk with different operating
system versions and they will let users
boot from external drives
they would support drivers for
peripherals and they will be amazing
unix machines for developers and the
scientific community that can run any
software
they like i don't know if you caught
that but he said booting from
external drives that's the first time
i'm hearing
anything about that we've made it really
easy to bring your app to any user
on any mac by making your app universal
the universal app contains code compiled
both for apple silicon
and intel processors the two binaries
become slices in a single executable
and the operating system chooses the
right one for the hardware architecture
of the mac
the user is running on everything else
in the app is the same
all the resources such as images and
machine learning models are identical
for both hardware architectures
this means you can distribute a single
universal app to your users
and it runs on any mac whether they use
apple silicon
or intel processors so this shows that
you don't have to make separate apps for
intel
and apple silicon macs but how easy is
it
this work will only take a few
engineering days even for some of the
most complex software packages
we've generally seen that it only takes
a few weeks to get the full version
up and running so just a few days
doesn't sound bad at all for common apps
we're also passionate about making sure
that open source projects thrive on the
mac
especially if they benefit the larger
software developer community and can
help accelerating the port of other
software packages
so we have already done the initial work
for some of the more widely used open
source projects to help the community
get started
and we'll be publishing patches to them
in the next days so apple has already
done the hard work
to bring all of those open source codes
to apple silicon
unity is an industry-leading platform
for creating interactive real-time 3d
content
it is used by millions of developers to
make games and apps that run across
apple's iphones ipads apple tvs
and macs now we've been working with
them and within just a few weeks they
were able to update their powerful 3d
editing and game development tools to
take full advantage of the power
performance and features
of the new macs built with apple silicon
as a developer artist
you can use the unity editor to create
edit and build your games
so let's see it in action here we have
loaded unity's spaceship demo project
into the 3d editor and it's all running
on a mac with apple silicon
unity plans to release a production
version of the editor runtime and tools
to enable you to easily create
build and ship your games optimize for
both existing intel based macs
and those with apple silicon so with
powerful tools like these we can't wait
to see all of the amazing new games
you're going to be able to create this
means that apple has been working
directly with unity to get their game
engine running great for apple silicon
getting it ready for game developers but
what about the current games that are
available on intel based max
what if the developers won't have time
to optimize them
before the release of apple silicon well
that's where rosetta 2 comes in
mac os pixel will include a new version
of our emulation software
rosetta 2. this provides compatibility
for existing mac software
now rosetta 2 is just an amazing
technology written from the ground up
for apple socs
allowing existing intel apps to run
seamlessly alongside your native apps
it's able to take intel executables and
translate them into native army
instructions
rosetta uses a number of advanced
techniques to let binaries run
very fast even during emulation this is
especially true for metal
where rosetta produces native calls to
the gpus built into apple socs so even
high-end games execute with incredible
performance
but is this actually gonna work well for
pro apps and games
well check this out okay let's take a
closer look at apps you saw earlier in
the state of the union
starting with dirt rally which really
shows off some great features of rosetta
the translation cache was built during
the install from the mac app store
completely transparently which means
there's no glitches due to a need to
translate new blocks of code
this is really important for games with
motion and real-time audio requirements
and things just work even this game
controller that i really need to be able
to stay on the road here
the cpu instructions have been
translated very accurately whereas the
graphics commands are sent through to
the native gpu
there's simply no frame drops or lags on
the controls it's amazing
he mentioned that rosetta 2 translated
the game to work on apple silicon
during the installation of the game so
there's no drop frames
and no lag for audio or game controller
input
and that's for every current game that
doesn't get rebuilt and optimized for
apple silicon
now let's look at a pro app affinity
photo which
really helps show off the emulation has
very little memory overhead i've got
this huge
82 megapixel image loaded here there's
no additional memory of it for having
such a large file open under rosetta
and because the translation cache is
file backed just like the original
executable
there's little additional overhead here
too and we didn't just focus on the
speed of translation
the translation cache is also secure
thanks to the code signatures that are
checked before execution
just like the original binary saving a
file is an all native operation through
our optimized storage stack
the emulation doesn't add any copies or
buffering coupled with native metal
i'm able to apply these effects quickly
and save them just as fast
so that was affinity photo running great
using rosetta 2 emulation
app extensions can be built as universal
binaries too
and since extensions run out of process
from the host app rosetta can even
emulate extensions
when they're being used with a native
host app so end users can rely on
extensions to continue working on macs
with apple silicon
while you are comporting them to run
natively and other standard plugin
architectures such as audio units run
out of process under rosetta too
drivers utilizing the driver kit api
introduced in macos catalina are in the
same situation
that was something i didn't know before
extensions and drivers are going to be
handled by rosetta as well
we are planning to make unmodified
iphone and ipad apps available in the
mac app store
once we launch our macs with apple
silicon in fact
all the apps that users purchased on
iphone and ipad
that are eligible to run on the mac will
simply show up as purchases in the mac
app store as well
you the developer will have total
control over whether you wish to
participate
so every unmodified iphone and ipad app
will simply show up on the mac app store
and run on an apple silicon mac on
day one including the apps that you
already
purchased let's look at an ipad game
monument valley
this app is the exact same one available
in the ios app store
when we launch it the app appears in the
dock like any other mac app
i can minimize and reopen the window
menu bar
is an important part of the mac
experience in ios apps get a menu bar
generated automatically
for instance the edit menu here with the
usual entries and the app menu as well
you will notice preferences here which
puts up an in-app preferences panel
automatically created from your app's
ios settings bundle so you can minimize
your game
and game settings will automatically be
routed
to the preferences page in the menu bar
we have our beautiful graphics
mouse clicks are mapped to tabs i can
zoom in as expected on the trackpad
i can click and drag to rotate and
create a path for our character
the game is fully playable so let me
remind you that that was an
unmodified ios game and apple is
automatically translating touch inputs
like taps
hold and drags and pinch to zoom to work
on an apple trackpad
or a mouse so a lot of simple games
will just work perfectly and as you saw
earlier
you can also use a game controller for
more complex games
and even better since apple is bringing
keyboard and mouse gaming support
for the ipad that means they're doing
the same
for the mac for game categories like
first person shooters
and moba games to achieve our users
expectations while also remaining
compatible with the apps we play a
couple of tricks
first we have a new app bundle format
which wraps your application as is
this allows the user visible app to be
freely renamed or moved
second to ensure that apps are launched
as compatibly as possible
we use a feature we introduced in mac os
sierra called app translocation
this allows the ios app to be
efficiently launched from a sanitized
path
that is not affected by the user's
actions so apple isn't just bringing
ios apps and games to the mac they're
doing everything they can
to make sure they run great with little
issues
so let's look at another ipad app called
documents
this application supports ipad
multitasking which means the window on
the mac is automatically resizable
i can even go into full screen
as you see here we have mac os scrollers
and i can scroll
with two fingers on the trackpad the app
automatically adjusts to macos
appearance
dark and back to light
and since this app supports multiple
windows on the ipad
it also does so on the mac now i don't
know about you
but that looks like it runs incredibly
well with multiple pages
and full screen mode in mind choose a
photo
and edit it i have an ios app installed
and it provides a photos editing
extension
this extension automatically appears in
photos extension list
i can choose it and enhance my photo
so when ios app extension is able to
work
alongside the native mac app
automatically
which i never expected the new widgets
are written in swift ui
making it easy to share code across
iphone ipad
and mac new widgets that work seamlessly
across all three platforms
this means that a developer can create
one widget for the iphone
and it should automatically work on the
ipad and apple silicon max
xcode's new swift ui app templates
include everything i need
to create common code to share across
platforms and then tailor
for each ui idiom these groups and their
targets are created automatically in new
projects
and help me keep good layering as my
project grows apple's goal is so that
developers can create common code
that works across all of apple's
platforms so there are minimal code
changes for each one
like adjusting the ui this is the next
big step
in bringing you a language and api to
build fully native experiences across
apple's platforms
without compromising on what makes each
platform unique all using swift and
swift ui
so that is apple's goal and i need to
remind you that this is
just the beginning at next year's wwdc
apple is going to continue adding
features so that developers need to do
as little work as possible
to write code for all apple devices at
once
there are so many new capabilities in
apis that we didn't even have time to
talk about here in the state of the
union
such as the new ways comml allows you to
encrypt machine learning models and to
deploy them via icloud
or tvos which continues to be the best
platform for the big screen
now with airplay support for 4k hdr
streams
multiplayer support for games and many
more new and enhanced functionalities
if you didn't catch that last bit
multiplayer gaming support for apple tv
games
is coming and since apple is blending
all of their platforms
apple is also adding multiplayer cross
play
between apple devices including the
apple tv
so hopefully this long video helps you
understand how apple silicon max
are gonna work much better than you
previously thought possible
and if you're wondering how good the
performance is gonna be
definitely check out the full playlist
right over there
or if you're interested in how gaming on
the mac is going to be revived
with apple silicon watch that video
right there
and be sure to click the circle above to
subscribe and check out our new
apple product merch in our merch shelf
right below this video
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one